and since his debut he's added two
quality pitches to give him four pitch
mix he can throw it up to 97 miles an
hour great movement good curveball
slider change up will he have to touch
early i know talking to him he's a cool
customer here from university of south
florida he's got all of the things you
want to be an opening day starter
in the playoffs
and fires and starts his night with a
strikeout you're going to see a slider
that's tighter and a change up that
fades so early on the first strikeout i
always said the first out in the
postseason game is awfully nice so
schwarber is on and bogarts is up there
goes schwerberg
but a second strikeout of his opening
inning for shane mcclanahan and a runner
in scoring position with two gone for
devers 24 year old rookie first post
season start
delivers him out 100 by devers baldy
starts the wild card game it's rodriguez
here for game one yeah rodriguez a
different style left-hander he's going
to be smooth late life on his fastball
and separation to change up with a good
tight cutter slider that he'll throw to
both sides of the plate the rose arena
is on and franco's coming up
cracks it base it into center field
over to cut it off fernandez franco
thinking two out of the box a jungle
from hernandez will send a rosarina home
raise one red sox nothing just like that
and it's rude and rbi doubled and
wandered front goes first postseason at
back there's the low pitch that he loves
and this little cutoff was pretty good
and then the bobbles all it took a
rosarina can fly two down in this first
unit here's yandy diaz
no one got in on him rolled the third
won't be an easy play endeavors on the
move diving plays safe and it's two
nothing tampa bay as diaz beats it out
goes run through two out
bishop vasquez floats the first one into
shadow center fielder kevin kidman
awaits and despite the first two
reaching for the red sox mcclanahan gets
out of it
[Applause]
the rookies shane mcclanahan goes back
at it first pitch swinging christian
arroyo smooth backhand play yandi diaz
one pitch one out what a great play
that's such a pick me up when you get a
first pitch out in the playoffs or any
other game that's huge pays up two
nothing is hernandez who struck out his
first time climbs in
up the middle
data wins here brandon wow for out
number two here he comes
hard stuff
grounder into short right field for lao
that's the first cleaning into the game
for shane mcclanahan does it on 11
pitches and with two out nobody on two
nothing race it'll bring up nelson cruz
and there's a high drive way up into the
air left center field verdugo back to
the warning track back to the wall
hernandez and it hit a ring and jumps in
play cruise around first we'll head to
second and now it's roll to homer he hit
the c ring
you've got four rings up there a and b
if it hits those
it's live and in play if it's hit c or d
in fair territory it's a home run and
that one did to make
two hits it
runs through three for shane mcclanahan
part of the order coming up for boston
here
it's a bouncing ball to brandon lau for
the first out of the fourth on a renfrow
back spinning pop up right side of the
infield
luplow dancing around devers to make the
catch two on two out one two is pulled
to third and caught by diaz
more good glove work at the hot corner
by yandy diaz for scoreless for shane
mcclanahan in his first big league
postseason start
vasquez hits one in the air the other
way
drifting back on it margot with roone
one away in the fifth inning of a
three-nothing game hernandez is over two
tonight
[Applause]
top of the order for the raise it's
randy rosarina to lead it off
high drive way back he'll admire it oh
my goodness oh my goodness long gone
his 11th postseason home run in 21 games
and it's four nothing rays
talk about lightning quick it's
lightning quick in the zone
i mean that's just quick to the ball
simple young powerful
and excitable you know one out under his
hunter retro 3-1 pitch grounded back up
toward the middle could be two brandon
now has it second out throw the first
double climb it goes four to three on
the twin killing for an assisted to take
care of bogarts and then the throw to
first takes care of retro rather easily
third picture of the game for tampa bay
it's david robertson resurfacing here
with tampa bay long time new york yankee
who hadn't pitched much in the majors
the last couple years starts the
sounding against verdugo who punches
about her left side wendell's there
steps into the throw to get him on
another 2-2 from robertson
lifts it in here to right that sends
margo back he's still going he's at the
wall with just enough room
a long second out quiet seventh here it
comes
swing ground ball back through the
middle but there is bronco to his left
straightens up bounces to throw diaz
backhands inside retired
what do you think they got the movie
theater butter on that
i i've never
i'm going to be honest i i
i've never seen baseball players eat
popcorn during the game
way up there off the bat of zumino and
left field verdugo can't seem to find it
oh it had to be a lonely feeling for a
moment and he's able to find it make a
catch now there is nobody close enough
to keep rosarina close to the back so he
can get off as far as he wants and
create a little bit of havoc for taylor
there goes rosarina he's still home
in october
he timed it up watch how he times it as
soon as he goes to that there was a
timing mechanism that was taking place
on every pitch that taylor threw see how
he goes through the leg kick and then
it's just a little too late to try to
make that move what an incredible
night for this guy oh my
randy arose arena set in october on fire
again this is the guy they went up to
rafael devers who loves the big spot
bases loaded one goal
one two pitch
ball
and the same awkward looking finish to
the swing as devers goes down on strikes
for the second time tonight by rising
not out of the woods yet on a 1-0 pitch
[Applause]
right side of the infield yandi diaz the
rays are out of the bases
fly ball right field
margot over the foul line and a shutout
win in game one for tampa bay there's
the equation all regular season long
dominant pitching and flare from some of
the young guys at the top of the order
arose arena and franco
michelob ultra organic seltzer as real
as it tastes